but what i love about this film
rogers and hammerstein cinderella is
that
we're going to see her and enchanting
light and she's going to change
so many others that
i never really got to see her in her
prime and i'm so glad that they're going
to see her in this light
and this is the light that she should
always shine in
how ecstatic were you to hear that this
gentle
movie is coming back for people to fall
in love with all over again
impossible for a plain yellow pumpkin to
become a golden carriage
impossible i couldn't believe it it was
you know i i heard so much chatter about
it i know the fans have been asking
about it
i believe there was a petition you know
and i know that so many people have been
hitting up disney plus like come on you
know this you gotta have you know rogers
and hammerstein cinderella on here you
know it's whitney houston it's
opening over come on so i i think
i'm so glad i'm so glad
that you know it has a home now it has
the perfect home
for this new generation to really just
soak it all in
and really understand that this is
something that they've never really
truly seen before
for sure and it's just just a beautiful
film and what a talented cast
of your time on set what comes to mind
as being
your fondest memory what does that look
like oh my god i have so many memories
um my fondest memory is is being in the
studio with whitney houston that that
was like
i was having so much fun i just it was
like
nothing that i could ever really imagine
because she's right she's right she's
right there and i'm like
you know yeah i spent my whole life
trying to meet her so
moments with her were like the best
moments with with
in terms of cinderella just i just
loved her so much still love her today
uh so those are those are my
greatest moments is with her i mean i'm
sure
imagine that film filming this had to be
like a pinch me moment time
and time and luckily girl e.t was on the
set with you
you know because we go back a a minute
here but e.t
right moment so i've got a little
surprise for you straight from set
starting with this look i'm going to
show you so
look at what you shared with us then on
set
okay i've always dreamed to be some type
of animated disney character
and um and to be the first
african-american cinderella that's
that's history that's never been done
before and i feel like it's a whole
dream working with
you know big celebrities that's been
around for a long time and i just feel
honored and it is a dream and my dream
has come true
oh little brand i know
what did you think of that moment brandy
what comes to mind
oh my god i don't even remember that
moment i don't remember so to see it
it's like i'm
seeing me but i'm seeing someone else i
know at that time i didn't really
understand
what really was going on i couldn't
really grasp
uh the history like i had the words you
can tell i had the word
but inside it's like i didn't really
know
that you know it was gonna be historic
and in the way that it was and it was
gonna have
you know such an impact and be so you
know revolutionary i didn't know that
you know i didn't have
that kind of mentality but i i didn't
know that something special and magical
was happening i was just so happy to be
around
you know my childhood idols and and
really work with them and learn from
them
yeah but i was i was over the moon about
it yeah
so young and you know now you know
now you know the implants that's bad how
proudly do you wear
that badge of honor for being the first
black cinderella with this incredibly
talented multicultural cast
i'm humbled by it you know because
whitney could have chosen anyone you
know but she chose me
and i am forever grateful for that
yeah well i want to hear another clip
with you this one is i feel like it's
incredibly
it's an incredibly special moment on set
that we just have to share with you so
take a look at this one
brandy and i have a very sometimes it's
um
big sister little sister right sometimes
it's a mother to daughter sometimes
it's sister to sister right you know it
it it it
varies on different levels it's
according to what we're talking about
what we're dealing with on that
particular day
are you okay brandi yeah i'm okay
of course i'm okay it's just
what a lot she's so um
yeah but what i love about
this film rogers and hammerstein
cinderella is that
we're gonna see her in this enchanting
light
we're gonna see her just so magical
and this is how we need to see her
because this is
her voice her talent her vision
for not just me but for this entire
cast in bringing this whole film to life
is it's unforgettable
like she has changed my life forever you
know and she's gonna change
so many others that
i never really got to see her in her
prime and i'm so glad that they're gonna
see her in this light
and this is the light that she should
always shine in thank you for sharing
that
of course and i just love hearing i mean
to have someone like whitney houston
who obviously you you idolized her you
loved her
her to say you had this big sister
little sister relationship
you know he'd be [ __ ]
i know and i felt that i keep all of
that with me
i mean she's always with me i feel her
always
yeah was there something like a piece of
advice or wisdom that she shared with
you that you feel like
you always kind of turn to it was to be
yourself for me and
i had a three-hour conversation with her
before she passed away
and that's what the conversation was
about she went into
depth about me staying true to who i am
and that was she made me promise her
that and
so that that has always been you know
just what i
i vow to do and i i live my life every
day
being more and more of myself beautiful
and that's
that sound and that can work in any area
of your life
yeah in your family life in your
professional life
being yourself being true to who you are
it's just
sets you free on every level you
yourself are
the mother of a daughter is your
daughter now
my daughter is 18. how it's
possible you look just shy of 21. i tell
you
just chef she's 18.
she's everything to you i can only
imagine my whole life
i just wow
she's so special to me did you share
this film with her
when she was a little girl i tried to
i tried to but it was hard for her to
see
okay this is my mom that's mom but
that's not mom they're beating up on my
mom with i don't want to watch it mom
i can't watch it
she has but not with me and it and it's
probably clips of it she probably hasn't
seen the whole thing
yet so now we're gonna we're gonna watch
it together now because she can handle
that
you know it's just a movie babe mom is
good
[Laughter]
he's doing everything on screen there
um how would you say that this role
impacted your career your life
i would it impacted my life on so many
levels it opened so many more doors for
me
um and in just in my career i was just
able to continue to do what i love to do
and then
later on in life i was able to do
broadway
and i just remembered you know all of my
cinderella moments
and you know being around some of the
most legendary
uh artists that were on broadway and i
was able to take that with me and take
it to broadway
and i absolutely love musical theater i
would love to do that in the future
more of that would you yeah yeah
i hope the broadway lights come on again
soon because i would love to see you up
there on the great white way that's
funny um i don't know if you're aware of
this
but this year marks the 25th year since
militia came out i know i know it's been
a quarter of a century
i know i mean i was busy back in the day
huh
yes and you still are would you ever
you know would you ever do a reunion a
reboot
something of the sorts with the movie
talking about it talking about it for
sure
definitely talking about it because
militia ended on a cliffhanger and i
don't think that's fair to the people
to the supporters that were with it for
so long and they're like
what happened you know what happened in
the end of it so
um that's one of the reasons why i'm
open to doing a reboot
some sort of special or something to
answer the questions that we didn't
answer
i love it what's coming up next for you
well i mean like i said more of what i
what i love
but my focus right now is to enjoy each
day
in february just leading up to this
beautiful magical moment
for the 12th and i'm just again thankful
to disney plus that they
really uh gave this
beautiful piece of art a place to live
and just
for people to relive it over and over
again
and dream the dream
you